[Música]
los líderes africanos llegaron a
bruselas para la cumbre de dos
continentes que no se realiza desde el
año 2014 hay más que nunca hoy más que
nunca europa está interesada en
fortalecer los lazos de asociación con
la unión africana ante pasos agigantados
de china y rúsia que en la última década
han aumentado progresivamente sus
inversiones en los territorios bruselas
se propone invertir 150 mil millones de
euros en la que es catalogada la cuna de
la humanidad para la transición verde y
la transición digital además la creación
de empleo la salud y la educación sigue
el sinsabor por un lento flujo de las
vacunas kobe 19 y también se buscarán
soluciones que promuevan la seguridad y
la estabilidad de niza el azotado por la
presencia de grupos extremistas para
ello entonces quiero saludar a nuestra
primera invitada del día ella es isabel
pascual profesora titular de historia
contemporánea de la universidad rey juan
carlos gracias por estar con nosotros o
profesora en nuestro espacio france24
directo médica primero hagamos un
balance de lo que las relaciones entre
áfrica y europa que ha pasado en estos
años desde que se celebró la última
cumbre
bien la última cumbre que se celebró en
el 2017 hace prácticamente cinco años
pues ya puso las bases para esta nueva
asociación que ahora se pretende
entonces digamos que esta relación pues
está lastrada por las relaciones
históricas de dependencia que ha habido
desde el siglo 19 sin embargo ahora
también a causa de la situación
sanitaria se ha llegado a conclusiones
ha llegado
ciertamente con mucha razón en estos
momentos que debido a la epidemia sanz y
la crisis sanitaria pues la
interdependencia es mayor lo había sido
siempre pero ahora hemos notado esta
vulnerabilidad y que si no nos
colaboramos y no ayudamos conjuntamente
no podemos salir adelante ni de la
crisis sanitaria ni de la crisis
económica entonces se ha comprendido que
hemos de estar cerca de nuestros propios
vecinos nuestros vecinos de siempre pero
que hay que atenderles y trabajar
conjuntamente
ahora también le pregunto profesora
isabel por qué es tan importante que los
europeos se posicionen de nuevo y con
más fuerza en áfrica cuál es la amenaza
que representa la influencia de rusia y
china en el continente africano
bien la amenaza es que pretendan o de
hecho lo hacen intervenir y ser unos
socios preferentes para áfrica entonces
esto es lo que europa que históricamente
ha estado allí no solamente en el siglo
19 con el colonialismo sino
anteriormente las relaciones han sido
estrechísimas por siente el el deseo de
estrechar los porque amenazan no
solamente con toda una serie de
inversiones y la forma en que se hagan
estas inversiones sino también porque la
forma de actuar que tienen por digamos
que no es una relación que no piden nada
a cambio y esto puede tener un flanco
positivo pero también puede tener un
flanco negativo
y además cuestan actualmente intentando
va a ser según parece que diversas
desinformación es de guerras híbridas
puede suplantar y reducir esta
influencia europea entonces europa
comprende que no puede ahora marcar una
agenda está diciendo exactamente qué es
lo que hay que hacer sino intentar
buscar cuáles son los intereses comunes
y así conjuntamente hacer una gente
ahora que podemos esperar de esta nueva
reunión realmente si funciona en la
práctica los compromisos adquiridos
si
va a intentar porque digamos que
objetivos había muy parecidos en el
pasado pero ahora parece haber la
intención de hacer este paquete de
inversiones mucho más concretas y tanto
relativas a la crisis sanitaria por
tanto en en vacunas en distribución de
vacunas en la posibilidad de que en
áfrica se puedan fabricar estas vacunas
también sino también en cuanto al cambio
climático que es vital vital para áfrica
también porque esto implica también
desplazamientos de personas y estos
desplazamientos afectan directamente a
europa ahora que puede hacer europa para
recuperar la confianza de los africanos
con conflictos generados como ustedes lo
decía también con la vacuna de kobe de
19 y todos los problemas de la región y
sobre todo en un punto que me quiero
enfocar que ya vamos a conversar después
y es sobre la relación con malí y el
anuncio que hizo el presidente macrón de
la retirada pero primero enfoquémonos
cómo pueden los europeos entonces
recuperar
la confianza de los líderes africanos
bien entonces primeramente buscando
una asociación pero que sea con una
agenda común con una agenda elaborada
por ambas partes por y buscando
necesidades mutuas intereses mutuos no
no imponiendo ninguna agenda no digamos
llevando la cabecera en este sentido
también ayudando a estos países en los
distintos problemáticas que van teniendo
primeramente en el tema por ejemplo del
tema de la seguridad y la paz ayudando
en este sentido no también con el
problema demográfico que son probables
del problema muy importante en cuanto al
crecimiento y un crecimiento que implica
que los jóvenes que llegan prácticamente
cada año a los 30 millones de jóvenes
llegan al mundo laboral en áfrica cada
año al menos hasta el 2030 puedan tener
acceso a una educación que haga un tipo
de empleo sostenible puedan acceder a un
empleo sostenible e igualmente también
con la ayuda por parte de europa
al acceso por parte de los africanos a
una serie de servicios básicos como
puede ser el agua la alimentación o la
electricidad que lamentablemente
solamente tienen acceso a ya un 50 por
ciento de la población entonces europa
tiene que buscar cómo ayudar en estas en
estas necesidades siempre pero
salvaguardando un trans una transición a
una energía verde entonces esto digamos
que es bastante complejo de llevarlo
adelante y por último con la ayudando
para la producción de estas de estas
vacunas entonces generando una relación
por tanto de confianza ahora sí
profesora el punto donde me quería
enfocar y en las relaciones de altibajos
entre malí y francia justamente hoy
parís y sus aliados entonces informaron
la retirada militar de malí tras nueve
años de presencia militar en ese país
para tratar estos grupos extremistas
tratar el terrorismo porque está porque
esta atención entre francia y malí que
pasa allí en esas relaciones
también en las relaciones con francia y
malí pues tienen
el origen esencialmente en cuanto al
pasado histórico por el hecho de ser por
el hecho de ser un país que fue
metrópoli y dominó toda aquella zona del
áfrica occidental y actualmente por la
presencia de estos grupos que están
dominando prácticamente el norte del
país y que están buscando una
independencia de esta parte norte
y por tanto que implica qué
digamos que francia no está dispuesta a
no está dispuesta a esta circunstancia y
digamos que quiere reducir estas tropas
estas tropas en el país el país no
quiere tener esta presencia entre
exterior los estos grupos con la
presencia exteriores son todavía más
violentos y entonces se buscaría que
estos gobiernos se reforzarán por sí
mismo y pudieran resolver esta esta
situación